Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P Here's an interesting voicemail.
A guy recounted a conversation he had with
someone he works with, I believe, and there
is such misunderstanding among right wingers
about such basic things.
Listen to this voicemail and then we'll discuss
it.
Okay?
Speaker 7: Hello, David.
This is Bob from Texas.
Yeah, I was having a conversation with a coworker
or my manager, I should say, and he was saying
he was complaining about the COVID relief
and saying that it affected his for one k
how much he could put into it or something
like that.
And oh, man.
And I explained I told them, well, Trump,
the two of them.
And, you know, you should be doubly mad at
him, right?
Instead of voting, you know, and and I just
had I'd probably do some research on my own.
But how does how does the COVID relief funds
affect oral one k and I know you're a big
finance guy.
You may have some insight on it.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So, listen, here's the first of all.
A ton of the.
So Trump has started saying this at his rallies.
Your 401 KS are doing terribly because of
Biden.
What does that really mean?
It's the stock market.
Okay.
When people talk about a401ka401k holds the
same types of assets anybody might hold directly.
So it stocks, stock mutual funds, bond mutual
funds.
So what they're really saying is 4 to 1 K
balances go up and down when the stock market
goes up and down.
So understand that when they talk about 401k,
what they really mean is the stock market.
Okay.
What some right wingers have claimed is that
COVID relief packages increased inflation
and therefore pushed down the value of the
stock market.
So as the caller points out, if you're mad
at Biden for doing that with one COVID relief
package, you should be doubly mad at Trump
for doing it with two.
The reality is that the effect of those COVID
relief packages on global markets and the
American market overall is quite limited.
But I actually think that's not even the right
conversation to have.
The right conversation is.
Zoom out and think for a second.
Does the stock market tend to do better when
there's a Democratic president or a Republican
president?
And the data are clear, the stock market on
average does better under Democratic presidents.
Now, the last couple of months haven't been
good under Joe Biden.
Let's wait and see what happens at the end
of his term.
It is not always the case, but it is usually
the case that stocks do better under Democratic
presidents.
When stocks do better for one, K accounts
do better.
Let's wait until Joe Biden's term is actually
complete.
We're not even two years in at this point
in time.
And by the way, look up all of this stuff
on your own.
Unemployment tends to be lower under Democratic
presidents.
GDP growth tends to be higher.
Job creation tends to be higher.
There tend to be fewer.
There have been fewer recessions under Democratic
presidents, even accounting for the difference
in number of years of Democratic for Republican
presidents.
Look it up yourself and then ask about causation,
correlation, and then we can have a real serious
discussion.
But these confused statements don't do much
for any of us.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I'm out of time but sign up at join pacman
dot com.
We've got a doozy of a bonus show for you
when producer Pat joins us.